crypto's in trouble but not for any of
the obvious reasons yes the prices are
way down but the real problem with
crypto goes way deeper and it's not
about the code either the core
technology works as expected the big
crypto debate right now is around use
cases basically what problems can crypto
actually solve that create real value
countless projects cover up their
terrible ideas by just slapping crypto
on there but these scams are falling
apart now the true believers are still
saying we're early all while the
cryptocritics are demanding clear proof
that crypto has real world use cases so
what is crypto actually good for let's
break this into three sections starting
with bitcoin the original bitcoin white
paper from 2008 focused on peer-to-peer
money transfer but it's been 14 years
now and bitcoin still isn't widely
accepted as payment for really anything
most people still use venmo or cash app
to send money to friends and when they
shop online they use credit or debit
cards and the reason is simple bitcoin
fees are really high especially for
small transactions now bitcoin
developers are working on the lightning
network to solve this problem but it's
hard to say if it will ever catch on
even if the transaction fees drop
there's still another big issue
volatility in 2014 i was running an
ecommerce site and we decided to accept
bitcoin as payment the price of bitcoin
kept going up so it worked out great for
us a customer would give us a hundred
dollars worth of bitcoin and in a few
months it'd be worth a thousand dollars
this creates a problem though if you
have a refund policy smart customers can
treat you as a hedge basically they buy
a product using bitcoin then if the
price goes down they sell the product on
ebay for dollars hedging their downside
risk if the price of bitcoin goes up
they ask for a refund of their bitcoin
from the company and send the product
back this allows them to capture the
upside potential of bitcoin without any
of the downside risk this scheme
obviously doesn't scale very well but
you can see how online merchants
wouldn't want to deal with this even
though the price of bitcoin has soared
over the past decade the number of
people actually using it as a currency
hasn't so what's driving the value here
well for a long time bitcoin has been
thought of as an inflation hedge and a
store of value it's been called a
digital version of gold and that seemed
like a reasonable theory at least until
this year since the number of bitcoins
is capped at 21 million it should be
resistant to the type of money supply
driven inflation that we've seen in
history when the government starts
printing ever-increasing amounts of
money the value of that money falls
rapidly and hyperinflation sets in this
simply can't happen with bitcoin so it
should be a decent inflation hedge right
well that's not what we're seeing this
year inflation is at 40-year highs it
should be bitcoin's time to shine but
it's in free fall so what's going on the
simple answer is speculation while a
certain portion of bitcoin buying and
selling might be informed by inflation
it seems like a bigger portion was
driven by pure speculation as the
government pushed down interest rates
and pumped money into the economy to
fight off a recession people started
buying riskier and riskier assets to
maximize returns instead of bitcoin
trading like gold it started trading
like a high growth tech stock so if
bitcoin can't be used to send money
easily or to protect against inflation
what's it good for well there is one use
case that seems to be holding up
protection against government seizure
across the globe authoritarian
governments threaten to seize assets of
their citizens all too often if you live
in a country where you think the
government might turn on you suddenly
storing a portion of your wealth in
bitcoin might be your best option when
you flee the country you could be part
of a religious or ethnic minority that
is about to be persecuted by a dictator
or you could just be a successful
business person who the regime perceives
as too powerful no matter the cause you
need to get out of the country and fast
traveling through the airport with a
suitcase full of golden diamonds isn't
likely to work but memorizing the
private key to a bitcoin wallet is
pretty foolproof it's tricky to put a
precise value on this authoritarianism
insurance but it clearly does provide
some benefit but bitcoin is only one
small part of the broader crypto
ecosystem the hot topic of the past few
years has been the second key area we
need to discuss nfts it's so easy to
write off monkey pictures as completely
useless and trust me i'm not about to
try and convince you that these are
worth anything but we still need to dive
into the underlying technology here at
their most basic level nfts are just
blockchain records that indicate
ownership over a particular digital
asset yes you can copy that digital
asset just like any other jpeg but the
whole right click save meme kind of
misses the point of art collection there
are plenty of perfect reproductions of
art out there but collectors still pay
millions for the real thing they care
about the history tied to the original
work and owning the real thing is
meaningful to them there's a problem
though the entire art market including
everything from ancient egyptian
hieroglyphs to contemporary paintings is
only worth 65 billion dollars last year
the nft market was worth 15 billion
dollars how could something only two
years old already be worth 25 of the
entire art market which spans all of
human history the answer again is
speculation tons of traders flooded into
the nft market hoping to flip jpegs to
the next buyer for a profit and for most
of last year they were successful now
even though there was clearly an nft
bubble does that mean that nfts are
completely useless
i don't think so but let me explain even
though the random cartoon nft might not
have any long-term value in the art
world that doesn't mean that digital art
as a whole has no value i actually love
digital art and think that nfts can work
in certain circumstances for example
this quilt right behind me was created
by an artist named libs elliott she
writes code in a programming language
called processing to generate the design
and then sews a quilt to match that
output i bought this in 2016 way before
nfts were a thing but if it came with an
nft to display the code or to prove that
i owned this particular design i think
that could be cool another example is
anders hoff he also makes generative
artworks and i've purchased a few of his
prints over the years the actual designs
are visually interesting to me but my
favorite part of his work is the code he
posts his code on github but buying an
nft of the art seems to make a lot of
sense here the problem is that there
just aren't that many great digital
artists out there the mona lisa is over
500 years old after all history is
really important when it comes to art
and history takes time there is one nft
though that i think could actually
become a historical artifact and don't
worry it's not for sale if we think
about why the mona lisa is so valuable
we can identify a few key ideas first
leonardo da vinci was an incredibly
important historical figure he was a
literal renaissance man and contributed
to astronomy botany cartography and many
more fields second the mona lisa
demonstrated many innovative techniques
for layering paint leonardo was actually
breaking new ground with the way he used
light emotion and posture to bring life
to the painting most nfts don't fit
either of these criteria they are
usually developed by anonymous people
and the artwork looks like it was copy
pasted from fiverr but there's one nft
that could fit that criteria over time
it's called at my whim and it was
created by moxie marlin spike now it's
clearly not the mona lisa but i do think
it satisfies our two main criteria first
moxie is an important person he's a
prominent cryptographer and the founder
of the signal messaging app his
cryptography protocol is what keeps
messages on whatsapp and google secure
second his at my whim nft is actually
innovative in my opinion see most nfts
just store a link to an image hosted
somewhere on the internet you might own
the nft but if the server that hosts
your monkey picture goes offline you
basically own nothing moxie took this
concept and exploited it to illustrate
some of the flaws with nfts at my whim
looks different based on where you view
it if you go to open c the nft will
display a spiral of lines but if you
look at the same nft on wearable the
background turns blue and the image is a
bunch of wavy circles it doesn't stop
there though as soon as you view the nft
in your wallet you just see a poop emoji
this kind of meta commentary is at the
heart of lots of high-value artwork just
look at john baldessari's tips for
artists who want to sell this 1966
painting is thought provoking because it
subverts the core idea of contemporary
art and because of that it's still on
display in museums today now will moxie
marlinspike's nft ever be worth anything
who knows it's not for sale but maybe
hundreds of years in the future it'll be
passed down as a memory of the nft hype
wave if it does there will be some
really interesting implications one
thing that makes nfts unique from other
art is that they are permanently tied to
the creator if an artist sells a
painting for a hundred dollars and then
years later that painting gets sold at
auction for millions the artist still
only has 100
but nfts can encode permanent royalty
rights that means every time the nft is
sold the original artist gets a cut
let's say hundreds of years go by and
that moxie at my whim nft winds up worth
millions well every time it trades his
descendants or whoever controls his
crypto wallet would get a cut that's a
big incentive for artists to use nfts
but it doesn't change the underlying
demand for art collecting at the end of
the day the most valuable art in the
world just doesn't trade very often and
that's part of what makes it so valuable
auction houses like sotheby's are
constantly on the hunt for valuable
artworks but even in the 65 billion art
market sotheby's is only worth a few
billion dollars in total at the end of
the day art collecting just isn't that
popular the average person doesn't have
the money to collect art they just want
to buy food housing and maybe have some
money left over for entertainment and
that's why a lot of nft promoters are
angling to frame nfts as not just art
but as utility tokens that grant special
privileges they say sure you might just
be getting a jpeg right now but in the
future you'll have access to some of the
most unique experiences money can buy
and by itself that's not completely
crazy if you spend a lot of money on a
piece of art the artist might invite you
to a private tour of their gallery you
don't need a blockchain to make that
happen though the blockchain becomes
important when those access rights need
to be irrevocable
just as bitcoin protects wealth from
government overreach the hope is that
nfts could prevent big tech overreach
here's how it works in theory let's say
i wanted to create more content but i
need a bigger production budget to make
it happen so i need to charge i have a
few options youtube has a memberships
feature where i could upload extra
videos to paying subscribers but if i
asked you all to buy a channel
membership i would be locked into
youtube if i wanted to do a paywall
newsletter later i'd have to get you all
to go over to a service like sub stack
now i could do a paid podcast behind the
youtube membership wall but lots of
people like to listen to podcasts
through apple or spotify and they
wouldn't be able to because their
membership was tied to youtube there
isn't really a good way to offer a
variety of content across platforms to
every paying supporter nfts could
theoretically solve this every member of
the community gets a token that can
prove that they are a paying member and
then access the premium content across
any platform this of course assumes that
youtube spotify and every other platform
are going to go along with this and
allow creators to share content
specifically to nft holders and this is
where it gets tricky see twitter and
youtube have both announced nft
integrations but it's extremely limited
and i'll explain why in a second with
twitter the nft integration is
essentially limited to linking an image
you own and then using that as your
profile picture you get a hexagon
instead of a circle and anyone can click
to see the nft's metadata but this
feature is completely separate from
super follows which are like youtube
memberships if i had super follows
turned on you would be able to subscribe
for a monthly fee and then see private
tweets from me behind the paywall but
there's no way to link these two
features and say look anyone who owns
this particular nft is automatically a
super follower and gets to see my
private tweets that might actually be a
good use case for nfts you hold one nft
and then can automatically see private
tweets as a super follower watch private
videos on youtube as if you were a
channel member and see paywall content
on any other platform i choose to
publish on
this is a big problem for tech companies
though in this scenario they make no
money if you pay for a channel
membership on youtube google gets a cut
and if you become a super follower
twitter takes a portion of that if this
were all powered by nfts the big tech
platforms couldn't take their fees so
they have no incentive to integrate at
this level the idea of a decentralized
record of memberships like this is
actually really great the creator gets
to have a direct relationship with their
audience and the tech platforms get to
focus on making apps with great user
experiences and this is a situation
where using a blockchain is actually
fully justified if one company
controlled the ledger they could change
the terms of the deal or cut off arrival
we've seen this in the past after
facebook bought instagram they instantly
stopped allowing twitter to repost
instagram photos but at the end of the
day these companies are profit motivated
and unless they are getting a cut of the
membership revenue they won't allow
creators to use these special features
for free so maybe we need entirely new
platforms and this takes us to key area
number three the reason that these tech
platforms are so valuable is because
they have network effects
no one wants to move from youtube to a
new video platform because all the
creators and all the viewers are already
here even if you build a better app with
more features getting people to actually
move and start using that new network is
incredibly hard this is called the cold
start problem and many crypto proponents
argue that tokens can actually solve
this everyone's seen the massive cycles
in crypto prices if you get in early you
can quickly make millions at the worst
these hype cycles are just ponzi schemes
in disguise but can this dynamic
actually create real value the idea is
pretty simple you launch a token
predictably the first people to show up
are speculators hoping to get rich quick
but while the token is pumping you start
adding real features improving the
service working tirelessly to create
real value over time the hope is that
you catch up to the hype and end up with
a network that has real users sure the
first people to sign up for your twitter
killer were only interested in the money
but now that it's up and running people
will stick around right there's a
problem with this though while it works
in theory finding product market fit is
a messy process and having a bunch of
fake users who are only interested in
speculation makes it impossible to
separate the signal from the noise what
you wind up with is actually an inverse
network effect your early users who
should be the most dedicated to your
project they wind up holding millions of
dollars in your token and they need to
sell the bigger you get the more selling
pressure there is as these mercenaries
move on to the next project they can
pump and dump we recently saw this with
a game called axi infinity the game had
a simple premise players collect digital
pets called axes and then battle them to
win rewards and level up it's a similar
core mechanic to plenty of successful
games like hearthstone and if they could
crack the code on amazing gameplay
everything would probably play out just
fine the problem is that the vast
majority of the playerbase is only
interested in the money-making potential
of the game so it becomes extremely
difficult to understand what features
will actually lead players to stick
around when it's not just about the
money bridging the gap between real
world and digital economies is nothing
new plenty of people made money farming
and selling gold in world of warcraft
years ago but that's not what kept the
majority of the player base entertained
if you search on youtube for world of
warcraft you'll find plenty of people
who are genuinely enjoying the game but
searching axey infinity shows mostly
tutorials on how to make money now
that's not to say that blockchain gaming
is doomed there is one crypto game that
does seem to have attracted a real
player base and i think it's precisely
because it isn't designed to make people
money it's more of a blockchain tech
demo and uses some really advanced
cryptographic features called zero
knowledge proofs the game is called dark
forest and it's important not to confuse
it with the d5 project with the same
name it's basically a space simulation
game but what's interesting about dark
forest is that it's open source and it
runs on a blockchain what that means is
that anyone can fork the code make
changes to the game and then run a new
instance of that game but they can't
cheat and see the entire map because the
map is cryptographically hidden and only
revealed to the local players it's more
of an experiment than anything else and
it certainly doesn't justify the
sky-high values we're seeing in the
crypto market but it does seem like
people are experimenting with this new
technology in a valuable way a
blockchain is just a new kind of
database that's it it might be hard to
describe the exact use cases of the
technology today but i'm still
optimistic that we will see interesting
and novel projects pop up in the future
blockchains do have the power to change
the fundamental economics and power
structures of the internet and that's
hard to ignore the prices might swing
wildly from one year to another and it's
possible that the whole crypto thing
never surpasses the 2021 peak but i'm
still excited to see what people build
the art market in crypto world fully
collided last year and to understand
some more of the limitations of crypto
crossing over into the physical world
just watch this video about a crypto
group that tried to buy the constitution
next thanks for watching